Tyla one was once known as the most
famously toxic League of Legends player
to ever exist but now well now he's
saving North America's amateur scene
with his Tyler one championship series
[Music]
applause seriously
the first-ever TCS was a huge success
with the finals peaking at 200,000
viewers from casuals to pros everybody
loved it where do you go from here you
beat the worst region but I mean sort of
the worst rage in error I mean where do
you go from here
I guess I'm wearing wheels I guess I'm
running the TCS Invitational oh I mean
you want to participate what to see it's
a little bit high class for you even
rides top dogs we're tweeting positively
about the tournament and these are the
same people who perma banned them from
the game in the first place
hey wait what and its success is a good
thing too because the fact is the TCS is
helping save the dumpster fire that is
na s amateurs see the amount of these
competitive leagues that European
players are able to play in due to their
national leagues and all the planes from
there compared to North America where we
have LCS 50 slots and Academy 50 slots
and that's that's it combine that with a
collegiate system where the talent
ranges from diamond to challenger in the
fact that there's only 50 spots in
Academy well soloqueue is one of the
only ways amateurs get noticed but there
is one shining light a grassroots
amateur tournament that people genuinely
want to watch one that gives
up-and-coming players a chance to shine
above everything else and the best part
is it was all started by one single
six-foot-five 255 pounds ravenmane
[Applause]
the Tyler won championships series he
started it back in 2017 when he was
still banned from League of Legends for
being super toxic in soloqueue
let's read it since 2017 TCS has run
every year with the 2019 tournament
wrapping up just this past month 2019
STC s featured 16 teams 96 players in a
$50,000 prize pool now the TCS doesn't
have the same production value as ride
events nor does it have the army of
people working on it behind the scenes
from hilarious commercials for his merch
to ridiculous green-screen skits the TCS
is full of comedy gold draw your last
pathetic card so I can end this you eat
my deck has no pathetic cards Kaiba but
it does contain the unstoppable either
[ __ ] one TCS casters are made up of
lovable personalities from both League
of Legends and the twitch community new
amphibian plus straight roads cold tis
too late now
you lost your chance to pull I've
doubled up all the way turning ayran to
scale even when the game on screen isn't
that exciting viewers are left
entertained by the casters antics
pretty accurate and you can be sure the
finals will feature a star-studded
analyst desk Obama but besides the
entertainment the TCS provides amateurs
a spotlight to showcase their talent to
pro teams Johnson cat evolved in prismo
are just a few of the players who either
joined an LCS or Academy team after
making a name for themselves at the TCS
to put this into perspective only three
players drafted at the 2019 scouting
grounds actually found a spot in Academy
with cat evolved being one of them
although it was TSM that picked him up
and not eg who originally drafted him at
scouting grounds
Tyler one's giving amateur players
something Bryant has yet to effectively
create a platform other than solo q to
show off their in-game prowess now
before you go writing in the comments
yes high paying and a small player base
are both factors that are affecting
potential na talent but those two
factors don't excuse na is poor
development system player base aside
just look at na Szold regional rival
Europe LEC has pretty clearly surpassed
LCS in the last few years it didn't used
to be that way and I think the single
most important thing that has happened
there is the regional leagues that feed
into the European masters tournament and
just comparing the scope of that amateur
scene with the scope of our amateur
scene like it's not even close EU
masters is not just a sub league for LEC
B teams it's a set of robust leagues
across Europe providing jung eum matures
hundreds of spots to compete in u
masters has created an amazing farm
system with tons of EU masters players
finding spots on LEC teams typically
speaking European rookie teams always do
pretty well it's not like a sure bet
that they'll be bottom teams every year
bar last year and last year's only
because promotion/relegation didn't
really exist anymore every every year
bar last year we sent a team of all
wiki's to the World Championships now
let's compare you masters to na Zanna
Jersey you have the 10 team Academy
League we're known quantities get tossed
from team to team each year and for the
ones not able to find a spot on an
academy team well I'm sorry to say but
you're basically out of luck the amateur
circuit right
created with faceit turned out to be a
glorified path for former pros to get
into scouting grounds I do want to point
out that this year they also had a bunch
of amateur tournaments that you could
participate in to feed into scouting
grounds and nobody's watching that Riots
amateur circuit grand finals averaged
around 311 of viewers peaking at just
over a thousand compare that to
Superliga one of the many EU masters
leagues that feeds into the Continental
tournament the Superliga finals peaked
at 54 thousand viewers and had a legit
live audience it's nearly impossible for
na to replicate the EU masters given the
player base and Tyler won proved that
with the TCS there can be healthy
alternatives to soloqueue and in 2020
Tyler promised to make the TCS even
bigger I really hope you guys enjoy it
this is officially the last TCS like
this we are going of at official
official huge stadium next TCS were
flight of it it's gonna be [ __ ] huge
the TCS as scuffed as it is is a case
study on how to give any amateurs a
platform in order to get noticed by both
fans and teams alike and who knew all it
took was one jak guy and some green
screens thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]